imagina que te encargan la organización
de los bocadillos para la siguiente
reunión familiar es una responsabilidad
muy grande porque debes de preparar los
bocadillos de acuerdo con los tamaños de
las charolas hay varios tamaños pequeña
mediana grande y jumbo si colocamos un
bocadillo en la charola pequeña cabe
perfectamente así que en la primera
charola cabe un bocadillo en la segunda
charola tenemos espacio para cuatro
bocadillos porque la charola mediana es
como si juntáramos cuatro charolas
pequeñas para la charola grande ocurre
lo mismo su tamaño es el de cuatro
charolas medianas y si las vemos juntas
la charola pequeña es para un bocadillo
la mediana para cuatro y la grande para
dieciséis cada uno puede tener cuatro
veces más bocadillos que el tamaño
anterior si nos piden a acomodar más
bocadillos cuánto medirá la charola
jumbo si aumenta al igual que las
anteriores aquí hay varias opciones cuál
será
tenemos una charola rectangular de 8 x 5
lugares así que caben 40 bocadillos otra
de 6 x 6 con 36 lugares una de 8 x 8 con
64 lugares y una última de 7 por 7 con
49 lugares para empezar sabemos que la
primera no es así que nos quedamos con
las otras tres opciones veamos cuál es
la jumbo hasta ahora nuestras charolas
llegan a 16 bocadillos para encontrar la
jumbo debemos seguir el patrón por lo
que la charola que sigue debe tener 4
veces más espacio que la charola grande
entonces multiplicamos 16 de cada
charola por las 4 que ya hay y obtenemos
64 bocadillos que caben en la charola
jumbo así que la opción es la charola
con 64 espacios que mide 8 por 8 lugares
así la charola jumbo sigue la progresión
que tenemos llevamos entonces 14 16 y 64
si fueron la reunión más grande y se
necesitarán más espacios para más
bocadillos
sólo hay que ir multiplicando la última
charola por 4 y así tenemos el espacio
de la siguiente en serio es muy fácil
espero que no tengas que llenar la
charola extra jumbo de 256 bocadillos
estaría enorme